il ya du soleil en bouteille et du
soleil en bocaux mais c'est surtout
ma réalisation la réalisation de mon
savoir faire voyez toutes ses conserves
hi-fi différentes sortes de partie ici
ce sont les confits de canard
laqué confit de porc de cette année ici
par exemple des couennes de la rue ici
des marmelades de la confiture de
pastèques ici encore des jarres et ici
des conserves de haricots blancs et la
plaine de conserves de canard
ici c'est mon coin regardez ce sont les
foies gras des foies gras de canard je
gardais comme ils sont beaux ceux-ci
jaune parce que ils ont été gavés avec
des mailles et jacques g sultan était
mère de famille puisque nous transit
lucent en femmes femmes au foyer
hervé dit le pape aux tiers parce que
j'ai passé beaucoup beaucoup de temps à
faire de la cuisine parce que nos skis
pour manger pour nourrir le monde
combien de personnes se trouvaient très
souvent 9 à table
[Musique]
voyez en ce moment je vais préparer une
vie belote de la fève alors je lui chez
les oignons et puis j'ai bien même
appareil électrique pour ces faits
maintenant depuis je ne m'en sers pas je
trouve ça sur ma planche s'arracher avec
le plus tôt j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
à cuisiner toutes les matinées et puis
même le soir il fallait savoir à midi
qu'est ce qu'on va manger le soir là
midi les hommes qui partaient travailler
aux champs avec les peut d'abord ils
prenaient le petit déjeuner puis
déjeunait casser la croûte alors c'était
du parti du saucissonne du jambon et
puis le repas de midi lors vous
programmé le matin pour le soir ah oui
il fallait prévoir il fallait prévoir ce
principe en avait et puis quelques
carottes
et les salsifis qui a dû avoir du mal
pour les harrachis
géré valoriser les produits de la terre
et les produits de la maison et les bas
morceaux sont devenus des morceaux de
valeur et qui maintenant font partie de
la gastronomie du coin
c'est un rituel de tuer le profond
youtube et puis nous faisons le bouder
mon mari sait les salaisons nous avons
un charcutier qui viennent nous aider
pour faire les sourcils épais nous
faisons des papes
fm au passé c'est aussi cela
voilà les deux mille sièges
lui le
manceau voilà et puis tu me donnes le
bouder le mange la sur le bli voilà
voilà et toi tu vas pouvoir rattraper le
jamboree le ferai celui là c'est celui
de l'année dernière
vous regrettez pas d'avoir perdu tous en
cuisine
maintenant oui je me demande
pourquoi j'ai passé tout ce temps à
cuisiner oui oui mais je n'ai pas su
faire autrement je n'ai pas non plus
faire autrement celui là je colle en
charge
vos enfants vont venir lors vous avez
prévu quoi je ferai une soupe de légumes
toujours pour honorer le travail de mon
match et puis y aura du pâté en croûte
puisque après le cauchemar j'ai fait un
pâté et dans une cocotte puis aura des
betteraves du jardin puis 2 au faux
et puis il règne le gigot l'autre de la
peine et puis comme retenir c'est une
rose se voit de guinée alors c'est une
pièce assez g de nous serons
certainement t1 à table vous pouvez
découvrir quand le vent se repeint en
enlevant saône au moins dix jours
quand on mange avec plaisir s'il ya du
plaisir dans la tour ça ne fait pas mal
je me dis que quand on aime les autres
et puis quand on aime manger et bien
sonné me faire la cuisine
[Musique]